everything we know about Carmelita
Torres is from a few newspaper accounts
in 1917 they called her an Auburn haired
Amazon just 17 years old she led angry
women in anti-american rioting and shut
down the us-mexico border but hidden
within her story is something much
bigger than a single riot it's a story
about American paranoia at the border
about a toxic campaign of disinfection
and discrimination and a u.s. practice
that would go on to inspire Nazi
scientists at the border between El Paso
Texas and Ciudad Juarez Mexico
thousands of people cross back and forth
for work and school every day they line
up in Juarez and often wait for hours to
get through the u.s. checkpoint but the
border didn't always look like this
crossing this border used to be free and
unrestricted people would come and go
without a passport
but after 1917 Juarez and El Paso became
two separate communities it was a
turbulent year at the border the Mexican
Revolution was ongoing and the u.s. was
about to enter a world war one all of a
sudden you have the war hysteria created
by World War one
people here in El Paso that are deadly
afraid that the Germans are going to
attack from cdot Juarez the fear of
invasion brought tensions to the border
while across the u.s. a different
movement was gaining strength the
eugenics movement based on junk science
aimed to create a genetically and
morally superior population that meant
stricter controls on immigration only
allowing those deemed fit to enter on
Ellis Island one of the busiest ports of
entry at the time
u.s. health officials were tasked with
weeding out immigrants they thought were
unfit or disease carriers and across the
country that process coincided with the
stereotyping of Mexicans as inferior and
unclean dozens of film titles included
the word greaser a derogatory term used
to describe Mexicans this racist
sentiment was strong at the us-mexico
border El Paso's mayor Tom Lee had
developed an obsession with cleanliness
and it defined his political platform
this obsession with not only racial
purity but physical purity he was going
to literally clean up El Paso
from all these bad elements and by bad
elements he often meant racially bad
elements one of Maryland's biggest fears
was a disease called typhus spread by
lice so under the pretense of sanitary
betterment work he helped lead a
campaign to inspect every house and a
predominantly Mexican neighborhood
if the inspectors found lice occupants
were forced to take vinegar and kerosene
bags have their heads shaved and
clothing burned hundreds of homes were
eventually destroyed Lee also expanded
the supposed health measures to include
inmates in the El Paso jail they had to
strip naked take a bath inside a tub
full of kerosene and on one occasion it
seems somebody laid a match 27 prisoners
majority Mexican or Mexican American
burned to death in the fire that the
newspaper is called the jail Holocaust
but despite the tragic fire merrily
pushed forward with even more aggressive
plans he sent a telegram a Western Union
telegram to Rupert blue who was the
Surgeon General up in Washington DC and
basically well let me just read in
hundreds dirty lousy destitute Mexicans
arriving at our Paso daily will
undoubtedly
and spread typhus unless a quarantine
this place at once the government didn't
agree to a full quarantine because
evidence suggested that typhus wasn't a
major threat in the area but instead
they funded a new disinfection plant at
the border in 1916 in this facility
every immigrant considered a
second-class citizen had to strip naked
their clothes were sent to a large steam
dryer and then fumigated with toxic
pesticides inside the gas room an
inspector would check each person's body
including private parts for lice if they
found lice immigrants would have to
shave their head and body hair and bathe
in a mix of kerosene and vinegar some
even had their eyelids checked for
things like pinkeye and many had to
complete puzzles or simple IQ tests to
prove that they were fit for entry after
this process they'd receive a ticket as
proof that they were disinfected but
they would need to go through this every
eight days in order to re-enter the u.s.
so many people didn't speak about it
they didn't talk about this humiliating
process like they kind of internalized
it is that psychology of shame the toxic
baths and dehumanizing inspections at
the border set the stage for a revolt
led by the 17-year old maid from Juarez
who defied the order to bathe Carmelita
Torres was I've compared her to the
grosser parts of the quarter in the
morning of January 28th 1917 there's
this electric trolley full of mostly
women that are crossing every day she
convinces the majority of not all the
women in that trolley to say no and to
refuse they start a spontaneous protest
there are accounts that in addition to
the humiliating delousing procedures for
women there was also sexual humiliation
there were rumors
there you know when they entered the
plant and then they were told to strip
officers were taking their photos and
then posting them in bars so I can't
even imagine the kind of feeling like
the feelings of violation and the
feelings of you know outrage
she was called an instigator a
ringleader you know but she was just a
young woman that was just sick of the
injustice of the humiliation that other
woman had gone through what started with
just 200 protesters that morning slowly
grew to a crowd of 2,000 reporter said
the scene reminded one of bees swarming
the hands of the feminine mob would claw
at the tops of the passing cars when the
American officers tried to disperse the
crowd they were met with bottles rocks
and insults protesters even laid down on
the tracks in front of the trolley cars
to create a blockade they were joined by
men in what's called the bath riots and
they shut down this border for two days
and then all you hear is that the
ringleaders are arrested and a few of
the men are publicly executed as for
Carmelita Torres it appears like she was
thrown in prison and as historians we
don't know what happened to her
afterwards we've lost every trace the
fumigations didn't stop after the riots
in 1917 alone over a hundred thousand
Mexicans were deloused at the border
that same year an immigration law made
border procedures even more rigid
immigrants at all points of entry needed
to have a passport
take a literacy test and many would have
to pay an $8 head tax and later that
year the US Public Health Service laid
down instructions for border agents
about who should be kept out of the
country imbeciles idiots feeble-minded
person's physical defectives persons
afflicted with Llosa more dangerous
contagious diseases
discriminatory policies at the border
resembled horrific events elsewhere in
the world in fact while researching this
David stumbled upon a detail the
fumigation of Mexican immigrants wasn't
just reminiscent of Nazi Germany it was
directly linked to it it's not so much
that the United States was copying Nazi
Germany it's the opposite Nazi Germany
was copying the United States he found
that in the 1920s the u.s. started using
zyklon-b an extremely poisonous acid gas
to fumigate clothing at the border and
in 1937 in a German pest science journal
a scientist called for the use of Zyklon
B and not C disinfection chambers he
included two photos of El Paso's
delousing chambers as an example of how
effective zyklon-b had been at the u.s.
border to kill unwanted pests the same
scientist pushed to use it to disinfect
concentration camps and eventually it
was used in concentrated doses to murder
millions of people people rightly so say
you can't compare what happened in Nazi
Germany with other parts of the world
and that's true in terms of cyclone B it
was used on the border not to
intentionally kill Mexican border
crosses but the history of something
like the Holocaust doesn't take place in
a vacuum a few decades after the bath
riots Mexico started sending men to work
on u.s. farms and railroads as part of a
new labor agreement called the bracero
program and through the program the
border dis infections continued
[Music]
here in this facility some migrants were
sprayed with insecticides this time it
was a substance called DDT a toxic
pesticide which decades later would be
banned for agricultural use by most
developed countries repeated contact
must be avoided they were sprayed in the
face they were sprayed in their private
parts and you know they were stripped
naked and inspected and sometimes
they're inspected like you would inspect
livestock first-hand accounts from
immigrants in the program reveal how
little they knew about the fumigations
so they talked about how humiliating it
was about why do they think we're so
dirty they'll call it the white powder I
don't know if they necessarily were told
were springing you with DDT but they'll
call it at all of all the powder white
powder that is helping to win the war
against disease many of the employees
who worked in the facilities weren't
given many details either when I first
started my role was a clerk I got the
job mainly because I spoke Spanish there
was there was a Hut in the area when
they came in from the Mexican side that
they were going going there and they had
some sort of it was for lice they said
it was you know to disinfect for lice
and we never gave it much thought
but we did think sort of look what the
Nazis used to do you know to the Jews
I had heard during lunch breaks that
they would spray him and and sometimes
there were comments from the men
themselves that they would put a host to
them I don't know if they knew what they
were doing to them I certainly didn't
know didn't it was far fetched from the
world we lived in
it wasn't until the 1960s when the
bracero program ended that health
authorities acknowledged the chemicals
were dangerous and the baths and
fumigations were finally discontinued
you want you want history to be about
progress about everybody realizes how
powerful it is and then it stops
unfortunately you know that that's how
it works
in movies but this was the border right
and the border a lot of things never
become resolved they just keep on
repeating themselves decades after the
disinfection campaign ended the language
the strategy and the dehumanizing
politics of fear and exclusion still
linger it's a health issue too because
we don't know what people have coming in
here coming in with diseases such as
smallpox and leprosy and TB that are
going to affect our people in the United
States just a fact you're gonna see
disease outbreak apprehensions in the El
Paso area specifically have spiked more
than 600 percent they are essentially
being warehoused as many as 300 children
in a cell without adequate food water
and sanitation the United States is
running concentration camps on our
southern border I don't like anything
compared to the Holocaust but why can't
you compare it his to his practices to
what led up to the Holocaust do we have
to wait for the actual Holocaust before
we speak out at the border between
Juarez and El Paso the same space where
the Baths riots once happened hundreds
of migrants have been huddled in
makeshift detention centers they've been
waiting to find out if the US government
deems them fit for entry
[Music]
as always there's so much information
that we couldn't fit in this video but I
wanted to leave you guys with one last
bit of information from David Bravo's
book so in 1918 the southern border
region was hit with its worst epidemic
in history and it wasn't typhus it was
the Spanish flu the best evidence we
have suggests it was actually from
Kansas brought to the border by American
soldiers just wanted to leave you guys
that tidbit thanks for watching and I
can't wait to share more episodes of
missing chapter soon